alright this is step three of how to
solve a Rubik's Cube and what we're
going to do now is we're going to
complete these bottom two layers in
order to do that we need to place four
middle edge pieces in these four
positions those pieces are going to be
the orange blue piece which is going to
go here
the blue red piece which in this case is
already here but it is flipped the red
needs to be here and the blue needs to
be here we'll have to correct that the
piece that's going to go in this spot is
the red green piece and the piece that's
going to go here is the green orange
piece okay so in order to do that we
need to look on the top layer in these
four positions for any of those four
pieces which we just mentioned they
can't have any yellow in them because
the yellow pieces are not in the middle
layer they're in the top so if we look
on the top layer we see that there are
two pieces the green red piece and the
green orange piece which do not have any
yellow and that are one of the middle
edge pieces which we need to place so we
can choose either one of those to start
with let's choose the the green orange
piece okay so what we need to do is we
need to look at the color that's on the
side of the cube in this case is green
what we need to do is we need to match
that green side with the green Center by
twisting the top layer like so once we
do that we need to see where this piece
needs to be placed well the color is on
the piece our green and orange so we
know it's going to be placed in between
the green and orange centers it's going
to be in this spot so that spot is to
the right of where the piece is now so
what we need to do is we need to turn
this spot we need to turn this piece
away from the spot that it needs to go
in if it needs to go to the right we
turn it to the left like so a quarter
turn what we then do is we look at the
other color on the top this time which
is orange and we take the orange side
and we lift it up towards you and back
down now that's the same move that we
did in the second step so if I take it
back and I put it there once we match
the green with the green side with the
Green Center we turn it away from where
it needs to go if it needs to go to the
right so it's going to eventually wind
up there but we can't just turn it like
that because what that does is it messes
up the bottom that we did in the second
step so we turn it away from the orange
side and then we take the orange side
this is the corner that is eventually
going to match up with this piece this
has orange and green on it and this also
has orange and green on it so once it's
turned away from that side we take the
side that it needs to go to the orange
side and we do right counterclockwise or
right up top clockwise or towards you
and then right counterclockwise or back
down so now we have lifted that corner
piece and we have oriented it so that
when we put it back down it will match
with this edge piece so let's do that
now we have the orange white green piece
here that we just lift it up that's the
piece that's missing so like it in the
second step we look at the color that's
on the side with white which is orange
we then turn the top layer until this
orange piece this orange side is matched
diagonally with its Center now it's on
the left on the left side the white is
facing to the left so we perform the
move left counterclockwise or left up
top counterclockwise or towards you so
we're going to bring those white pieces
you should see a line now a white line
and then you bring it back down and what
that does is it places that edge piece
in its proper position so this green
orange edge is placed in between the
green and orange centers and it is in
the correct position so we have to do
that for the remaining three edge piece
the middle edge pieces that need to be
placed down so we look on the top and we
find that there are two edge pieces here
on top the green red and the blue orange
which need to be placed the other two
are the pieces which have yellow in them
and we do not want to touch those so
what we need to do is we need to pick
one of the top colors one of the top
edge pieces such as the blue orange and
we turn it so that it's matched with its
center color which is blue then we need
to see where it needs to go well it
needs to go here it needs to go in
between the blue and orange centers so
what we need to do is as in the other
step the other edge that we placed we
turn it away so in this case we're
turning it towards the right then we
look at the color on top which is which
is orange we take the orange side and we
do perform that move which is left
counterclockwise top counterclockwise
left clockwise what we now have done is
we lifted this corner piece and it's up
here so you look at the color on the
side with white which is orange and you
match that orange color back up with its
Center we then hold the orange Center
and the white is on the right this time
so we need to perform the move that
corresponds with the right side that's
right up or clockwise now that's matched
up with its edge piece the top goes
clockwise or towards you so now you
should see another white line and then
you bring the right side back down or
counterclockwise and what that has done
is it placed the orange blue edge piece
where it needs to go in between the
orange and blue centers so now if we
look on top this piece has yellow it's
no good this is how yellow it's no good
this has yellow that's no good and this
is the only piece we can work with now
on top so what we need to do is we need
to match this piece up with the green
Center so if we twist the top layer so
that is matched with the green Center
it's now in the correct position for
putting it plate
down so we see where it needs to go well
it has red and green on it so it's going
to go down here on the left so what we
want to do is we want to turn it to the
right we want to turn it away from the
position that it needs to go in so once
you match it up you turn it away from
where it needs to go we then take this
side with the color on top which is red
and we lift it up or counterclockwise
since it's on the left top goes
counterclockwise or towards you and the
left side goes back down or clockwise so
now this is the last edge the corner
piece that we have lifted which is now
here so we look at the color on the side
with white which is red and we match it
diagonally with its center once we do
that the right the white color is facing
the right so we take this piece and we
turn it right clockwise then we turn the
top clockwise or towards you now you see
another white line on the right and then
you bring the right side back down or
counterclockwise so now we have three
pieces which are in the correct position
now the last piece is already down there
and if you remember me explaining it
this has to be flipped so what we want
to do is we want to do that same move we
could either hold it like this with the
red or we can hold it like this with the
blue either way you're going to get
those two pieces you're going to
separate them from where they are so
let's do it we'll do it on the left side
so we'll hold it on the left and we lift
it up or left counterclockwise then the
top goes counterclockwise or towards you
and then the left side goes back down so
now we have these two pieces up top what
we need to do now is we need to place
this corner piece back down so we match
it with this Center color which is blue
and then we bring that the same thing we
bring it
up or right counter right clockwise and
then top towards you or clockwise and
then right back down now we have
separated this from that flipped piece
that was originally here which is now up
here so now we can perform that move
that we've been doing by matching the
color on the side which is red so we
turn the top until it's matched with the
red hold that Center red piece and now
we see that it needs to go back down
here but it needs to go in the correct
position so that's the left side it
needs to go to the left so we turn it to
the right we then take the side that has
the color on top which is red sorry
which is blue and we lift that blue side
left it's on the left side so left
counterclockwise top counterclockwise
and left clockwise or back down so now
we have both of those pieces up here
what we need to do now is we place this
corner piece we look at the color that's
on the side with white which is blue we
turn it so that the blue is matching
diagonally with its Center and now when
we place this back down it is going to
meet up with this blue red piece so we
do the same move it's on the right side
now the white is facing the right so we
do right clockwise top clockwise or
towards you now we see another white
line and we bring the right side back
down now if you look you should have two
completed bottom layers and you should
give yourself a pat on the back because
that was one of the trickiest steps of
solving the cube the next step is step
four and we're going to be trying to fix
this top layer which is the last layer
that needs to be completed